didier pittet merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation directe ur rt france
alors les nouveaux chiffres concernant
l'évolution de l'épidémie sont les
suivants santé publique france
enregistré 3082 nouveaux cas de
contamination alors que penser de ces
chiffres est ce qu'on est clairement
aujourd'hui dans le scénario d'une
seconde vague
alors écoutez on est typiquement dans un
scénario qu'on pourrait comparer au
scénario du mois de février ou mars mais
il ne faut surtout pas le comparer en
matière de chiffres pourquoi parce qu'à
l'époque en france comme ailleurs
d'ailleurs dans tous les pays du monde
nous manquions de capacités de test à
très large échelle
alors qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas
et en france notamment
vous avez une procédure de dépistage
pour toute une série de raisons qui est
extrêmement actif et ce c'est cette
procédure de test au moindre symptôme de
test alors que vous avez peut-être été
en contact voire de dépistage large dans
les situations à risque voire même en
dehors des situations à risque qui fait
qu évidemment plus on cherche plus on
trouve et c'est toujours ainsi en
épidémiologie alors ces derniers jours
avec une baisse du nombre des
hospitalisations n'a pu entendre ici ou
là certains parler d'un virus moins
virulent c'est en leur nom c'est ce
n'est pas le cas je crois que on peut
avoir quelques hypothèses mais ça n'est
pas le cas la raison pour laquelle
n'avons pas ou très peu de
spécialisation et très peu de speak
alisation en réanimation est tout
simplement qu'aujourd'hui les personnes
qui sont testées positives sont les
personnes en grande majorité d'âge
relativement jeunes voire très jeunes et
ce sont les personnes en bonne santé qui
ne tombe pas malade et qui n'ont donc
pas besoin d'être hospitalisé c'est la
raison pour laquelle finalement ces
données sont très importantes parce qu
elle nous renseigne sur la situation
épidémiologique comme on aime en parler
et qu'elle nous rassure aussi par
finalement l'absence d'un taux important
de spécialisation mais c'est là la
véritable défense contre cette épidémie
parce que
à chaque fois que nous détectons des cas
positifs nous pouvons évidemment décidé
de 40 m et décider d'intervention qui
limite les risques pour les
personnalités et les personnes
vulnérables qui sont vraiment les
personnes qu'il faut protéger en premier
alors avec la rentrée nous entrons bien
évidemment dans une période à risque 1
ce week end
des médecins ont d'ailleurs alerté dans
une tribune publiée par le quotidien le
parisien
pour eux le produit cole sanitaires
mises en place par le gouvernement
français dans les écoles est trop léger
et il préconise entre autres le port du
masque obligatoire dès l'âge de 6 ans
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors écoutez le port du masque
obligatoire est une discussion qu'il
faut avoir rappelons que les deux
mesures essentielles sont évidemment la
distanciation physique ou la distance
sociale selon comment on veut l'appeler
idéalement d'un mètre cinquante
au moins entre deux élèves ou mais avant
tout entre l'élève et le professeur
ainsi que l'hygiène des mains qui est
absolument fondamental le port du masque
n'est recommandé que dans la mesure de
laquelle la distanciation physique ne
peut pas être respecté rappelons
également que en règle générale les
adultes qui sont des enseignants ne
court pas un risque exagéré d'acquérir
la maladie a à partir des enfants les
enfants même s'ils sont porteurs du
virus y compris en grande quantité la
plupart du temps ne transmettent pas
nous avons d'énormes données
épidémiologiques pour rassurer à la fois
souvent les parents mais aussi les
enseignants et je crois que c'est très
important de le rappeler
rappelons aussi que au début du
confinement
certains épidémiologistes dont moi même
d'ailleurs n'étions pas pour la
fermeture des petites écoles
au contraire nous voulions garder les
petites écoles ouverts et à ce moment là
il n'y aurait pas eu de masques dans les
écoles en suisse nous avons décidé au
port du masque au delà de
l'âge de 11 ans et d'envoyer qu' on est
encore plus large
dans les recommandations que ne le sont
les recommandations françaises alors une
dernière question pour le moment ni
médicaments ni vaccin pour autant est-ce
que la connaissance du virus a évolué et
est ce que la prise en charge des
malades
elle aussi a également évolué
aujourd'hui alors écoutez la
connaissance du virus et de son
épidémiologie a largement augmenté nous
en avons beaucoup plus nous nous pouvons
confirmer que les mesures barrières qui
ont été mises en place depuis le début
sont bel et bien efficace évidemment
sous réserve qu'elles puissent être
respectés c'est ça toute la
problématique mais l'épidémiologie le
prouve bien
en matière de traitement tout l'avancé
peu d'avancé en dehors de la situation
des cas extrêmement grave qui en
réanimation bénéficient d'un traitement
aux corticostéroïdes et de quelques
nuances par rapport à la durée
d'hospitalisation qui sera raccourcie
sur l'utilisent leur md et dire mais en
dehors de ça nous n'avons pas obtenu
d'avancée très significatives en matière
thérapeutique
nous savons qu'il ya des avancées sur le
vaccin mais il est encore bien trop tôt
pour espérer que le vaccin soit là il
sera probablement là en 2021 et pour
l'instant les mesures barrières restent
les mesures principales de prévention
avec le fait d'aller évidemment se faire
faire un test diagnostique à la moindre
suspicion de symptômes de maladie
c'est entendu merci beaucoup didier
pittet d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes infectiologues
et épidémiologistes suisse